[Musique]
oui mais n'apparaît pas comme si nous
sommes à lundi puis aujourd'hui c'est
une journée parfaite pour le sujet que
j'ai choisi après les quelques semaines
à 7 ans d'information près dans ce très
difficile au niveau émotionnel et bien
j'ai la chance de pouvoir dire que les
médias sociaux cette semaine était
rempli de planification voyages de
vacances l'été qui s'en vient d'ailleurs
aujourd'hui ont maintenant une journée
de 20 degrés en plein début du printemps
ça donne espoir et je pense que vous
voyez mon petit monde ça tiraille
estivale et je dois avouer que moi même
je suis extrêmement excité à l'idée de
recommencer les parois d'aller visiter
ma communauté c'est beaucoup de plans
qui se font et on entre à peine dans le
monde mais il faut vraiment vraiment ce
début je suis parce que ce que je vois
c'est que tous remplis les campings les
arbitres ou et l'empreinte se remplit
rapidement parce que y'a pas que les
communautés autochtones qui sont
vraiment excités à l'arrivée de la
saison chaude les communautés à
l'automne aussi et dans les deux
dernières années avec je pense qu'il ya
un éveil collectif par rapport à la
grande distance qui existe entre nos
communautés mais de plus en plus de gens
sont intéressés à venir visiter les
communautés et donc je veux vous offrir
quelques conseils pour pouvoir essayer
de vous donner une piste pour préparer
vos vacances justement si vous voulez
venir nous visiter dans nos communautés
première piste tourisme autochtone au
québec c'est vraiment une ressource
incroyable des années travail à faire
connaître les ressources touristiques
les services qui sont offerts dans les
communautés des fois même les offres de
services comme l'hébergement les rêves
la restauration donc aller sur leur site
même où un journal qui publie
annuellement avec la ressource avec
information je me souviens même quand
j'étais animatrice au jardin botanique
on offrait le guide parce qu'il y avait
une carte des premières nations à
l'arrière et c'était une des premières
qu'on pouvait vraiment de distribuer au
grand public pour leur faire découvrir
les onze nations du québec est de plus
en plus de gens aujourd'hui ils
connaissent mes onze nations mais à
l'époque c'était pas étonnant que
personne ne savait et c'était comme une
petite bible j'étais ravi communauté et
en plus
ddd nom des nations c'était vraiment
fantastique à offrir un cadeau qu'on
peut donner aux visiteurs aux touristes
qui voulaient en savoir plus une autre
source que je peux vous afrique et en
anglais cependant ces parois points
comme si vous voulez faire la route des
parents qu'on appelle vous prévoir
un bon budget
voyages ça doit pouvoir aller partout en
amérique non pourriez faire la parole à
chaque fonctionnelle sans aucun problème
que ce soit au québec au canada aux
états unis
mais vous savez comment suis-je arrive
tout à jarry avec le gardon mais a
précisé l'avertissement il faut vraiment
être prudent cette année parce que on a
encore cette réalité qui est la copie et
qui n'a pas touché de façon égale les
milieux urbains les communautés qui sont
reliés aussi avec des routes et les
communautés qui sont un milieu éloigné
ce jeu je pense beaucoup par exemple aux
croisières en bateau qui vont aller
recommencé à se rendre dans le grand
nord des territoires du nord-ouest en
alaska et ce sont des communautés
éloignées qui ont bénéficié de
l'éloignement que parfois d'un fond la
vaccination pas été fait de façon égale
on a pu voir la différence dans
certaines communautés quand une
vaccination de masse yves a été fait et
versus une vaccination très légère les
causes de mortalité augmenté et on sait
que c'était une grosse problématique
était soulevée pour les communautés
autochtones on a une problématique liée
aux maladies pulmonaires il ya des
maladies chroniques aux six ans combiné
à ça donc faut vraiment vérifier si une
communauté est ouverte au tourisme
parce qu'ils sont quand même capable de
gérer leur propre tourisme de décider si
les restes sont acceptables selon le
niveau de protection de la communauté et
en même temps voir si la ressource est
là pour vous accueillir pour pas que
vous ayez mauvaise expérience après ça
devienne un reproche aux communautés
faut pas oublier qu'on n'est pas encore
notre développement touristique énorme
puisque par le passé les gens ne nous
visiter pas malgré le fait qu'on est
dans la même province hélas de plus en
plus grosse justement vos deux dernières
années les gens ont découvert
le tourisme québec les gens veulent
aller visiter leur propre province est
de plus en plus haut si les gens veulent
visiter les communautés autochtones dont
juste vous assurez par un manque que la
communauté est ouverte la communauté
peut vous offrir des services vous
desservir justement que ce soit au
niveau de l'essence au niveau même de
l'alimentation du logement est aussi qu'
ils ont la capacité de recevoir de grand
nombre parce qu'il faut pas oublier que
quand je parle de communauté par exemple
nouvel environnement un bateau de
croisière qui les daaf tout d'un coup
c'est une ville qui débarque dans un
village alors juste de pouvoir vous
préparer pour qu'il soit agréable pour
vous et pour les gens qui vont tous
recevoir alors n'hésitez pas à partager
cette traînée n'hésitez pas non plus à
nous donner des conseils tourisme
surtout si vous venez de communautés
éloignées et que vous voulez juste avant
que ça se passe super bien et
l'expérience soit agréable pour tout le
monde d'ailleurs n'hésitez pas de plus
en plus on va voir justement des vols
qui sont facilitées en région on va voir
des gens qui vont vouloir faire des
offres de airbnb de leur maison parce
qu'ils sont il travaille en milieu
urbain mais pendant l'été leur maison et
vacances donc explorer apprécié mais
soyez quand même prudent et respectueux
par rapport aussi l environnement que
vous allez visiter pour ne pas laisser
derrière des mauvais souvenirs en tant
que visiteur alors je souhaite une belle
semaine